I'm actually surprised that you guys are
here for this
um I'm I was waiting for you guys to
come
pick me up
to something that happened earlier
yeah okay very uh ashamed
about this I'm very embarrassed okay but
I had a drone and I actually
flew it in the neighbor's yard and
we would like to clear this up if you
would like to come down and speak with
the Texas that's going to be handling
this case and clear the air today we we
would appreciate that it's my only my
only fear is that I'd go down there and
I speak to the detective and not with
legal representation and then I end up
staying there
how you doing
moments
yeah I uh I already spoke to you know
they were worried about you for
something
I called the owner I called the uh
uh
um the second in charge
yeah they they said that you had called
they were more concerned because
apparently you never call out you're
always there and they were just the way
you were saying sorry they were just
very concerned about you for whatever
reason I'm not sure why but
I'm actually surprised that you guys are
here for this
um um
I was waiting for you guys to come
pick me up
for something that happened earlier
yeah okay have you talked to anybody
about that what do you mean like
detective wise or anything no do you
still have to are you still register no
I mean that that my prior incident
that's all that's all done it's almost
25 years okay okay all right all right
this is a new
issue okay okay
which um I was uh contacted by the
family last night at 10 30. okay
it's basically invasion of privacy okay
um
very uh ashamed
about this I'm very embarrassed okay but
I had a drone and I actually
fluid in the neighbor's yard and
which I thought that
that was what what we're here for right
now yes
um
let me tell you what I'll make a phone
call to give you some peace of mind to
see if there's anything that's happening
with that all right is that the reason
that you called out of work as you
expected us yeah right yeah I I want to
eliminate all right
[Applause]
all right Christopher just come here for
a minute all right
no weapons nothing on you right no just
got patch you on quick okay
just your wallet all right
you can even keep that on you just walk
over my car you're just being detained
right now just because of the statements
you made to us we're still trying to
figure out what's going on okay okay so
like I said you're just detained you're
not under arrest so just have a seat in
there okay you've been nothing but good
with us and we really appreciate that
okay just give us give us a few minutes
to figure some things out all right I
know uh I know your jobs are hard and
okay well like I said we really
appreciate I'm actually gonna have you
just take your wallet out I think so
foreign
Christopher you doing all right back
here yeah all right we're just waiting
for the supervisor to get here okay okay
all right
all right Christopher step out for me
yeah this bag too all right all right so
here's what's going on
there is an investigation okay yeah
obviously you're aware of that you kind
of know what's going on right
we're asking if you would like to get in
your own truck follow us down to the
station speak with the detective that's
going to be handling the case maybe it's
a massage thing maybe it's not we don't
know it's still being investigated so as
of right now there's no charges against
you okay yeah so we're not going to take
you if you would like to come down to
the station and clear this all up on
your own we would really appreciate that
yeah it's
completely up to you at this point
well there's no charges against me right
now okay we would like to clear this
whole incident up obviously you you came
out and you said some things to us right
we would like to clear this up if you
would like to come down and speak with
the Texas that's going to be handling
this case and clear the air today we
would appreciate that like I said it's
completely up to you yeah my only my
only fear is that I go down there and I
speak to the detective and not with
legal representation and then I end up
staying there
you know if if you'd like to call call
an attorney speak to whoever you need to
and then come down and speak with them
the owner of my company I spoke to him
this morning okay and
uh he has a lawyer that he uses and uh
he was going to run the situation by him
okay to get his legal advice okay and
then refer me to someone who specializes
in
this sort of uh what would be a good
phone number for you uh myself
like I said we really appreciate you
being so Cooperative with us well and uh
you know I mean like I said before you
guys have a hard job and
uh you know not that's why like I said
you you have your rights and we're not
going to say you have to come down we
would like to clear this up today and
whoever you end up talking to just if
you would like to come down and
clear the air clear whatever this is up
we'd be more than happy to get this done
and over with today okay okay so like I
said you're you're absolutely free to go
Okay so
all right well I appreciate your concern
for originally yeah yeah no that was
that was the whole thing is they were
very concerned about you yeah well I'll
make a call to them and just let them
know that I'm okay and you know I mean
the owner and the uh operations manager
I was more more forthcoming with them
yeah on the situation yep uh my second
in command because I'm the warehouse
manager yep
um I was a little vague with him yeah
just because you know and that's
probably the one that called because
they they said you didn't seem like
yourself when you called you were saying
sorry a lot which made them think they
had no idea what was going well this was
and apparently you don't call that work
so I don't I I the only I think the last
time I called out of work was when I
broke my toe box that was I don't know
five years ago all right
um
but yeah yeah I would like to um uh help
you out the best I can but I would like
to you know speak to some legal like I
said there's there is an open
investigation okay and and we the Texas
would like to speak with you but like I
said you you don't have to go down there
we would like you to clear it up but you
you don't have to right now yeah okay
but we do appreciate the cooperation
okay I appreciate you all right your
concerned all right
you guys
foreign
[Applause]
yeah please yeah
yeah
I knew when you guys hung around that
I'm gonna take you out of your pocket
okay oh yeah
all right
[Music]
I don't want those to hang up on you
[Applause]
I gotta have some
get you right out here back to the
station okay
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't see supervisor on senior G13 for
the mail
Pennsylvania
yes we're gonna explain all your charges
a second we get back to headquarters
okay
are you on probation or parole right now
all right so with it being 11 o'clock I
don't know if there's afternoon session
of Court okay hopefully there is and we
can get you right down there
all right if there's not we'll have a
Justice of the piece come in it won't be
till a little bit later though okay
so
I don't know if you know this
will I be spending the weekend I don't
believe so if you're not on probation or
parole you'll get you'll get uh you'll
get bail on this and you'll be you'll be
out
okay do you want that window down it's
kind of high in here
okay just the crack that's that
um
well if
some
um
if I could ask
a professional courtesy
my mother is class seven years yes
I am afraid of retaliation yeah okay
that's that's not a problem we can we
can make checks of the house in the area
but I I'm telling you I I I'm pretty
sure you're out today probably if they
have afternoon Court we'll be taking it
right down there
as long as you're not in probation or
parole you're getting charged with
disorderly conduct and you'll you'll be
out
I don't I don't see them holding you
without pale for a a misdemeanor charge
but that's as long as you're being
truthful about not being on probation or
parole
59. yeah have you been arrested since
then no no okay I'm I'm guessing you're
not on probation parole anymore and
you'll be out today
all right
boys listen that's something I'll check
it right when we get to uh headquarters
what's gonna happen is I'm gonna put you
in a Cell I'm gonna run grab some
paperwork I can do a photograph
fingerprints and then we're gonna get
you right down to court if there's an
afternoon session all right
try to do this as fast as we can get you
get you on your way all right
go ahead very much appreciate you being
cooperative
yeah
um and um
that is something you'll have to figure
out you don't have a cell phone with you
correct no
no all right well uh if you're leaving
from our station we'll give you a phone
call we'll uh we'll find a way to get
you home if not if you're if you're
going right down to Court in Warwick
they'll have a phone for you you can
call a cab call uh
call really whoever you want to get you
home from there I'm not sure
I know this bus stop right out front I
don't know if that's helpful to you or
not I don't know the bus schedule but
we'll uh we'll try and figure that out
see first we'll see where you're going
to be leaving from okay
then then we'll come up with a plan for
you